Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. You probably saw the news
recently that Marvel was doing another wandavision sequel series for white Vision
this makes the second one
two spin-offs for wandavision that's how popular
it was we also found out when Scarlet Witch
is coming back and another big announcement
for another series Marvel's Wonder Man which has a
lot of Easter eggs for white Vision in the comics
if you're brand new to the channel of course
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes when
it premieres just like I do for all the other
Marvel Disney plus Series be sure to subscribe
to get them and because black panther wakanda
forever is coming out in theaters really soon
we're doing a giveaway for IMAX tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
post all your theories for white Vision in the
comments many thanks to Marvel snap for asking to
sponsor this video too who wanted me to tell you
about the new video game you probably saw that new
Nick Fury clip that was for Marvel snap someone
left your termination papers on the printer Fury
I'll try to spare the world from Evil overlords
better next time it's a new video game from the
people that made Hearthstone it's a card based
game each round takes place over six turns with
three random locations each turn a player is
granted an extra unit of energy to play cards
turn one equals one energy turn two takes two
energy and so on turns happen simultaneously so
each player in a game makes their move at the same
time during each turn location cards are the three
cards in the middle of the board that reveal one
turn at a time until turn number three you have
to overpower your opponent at two of the three
locations to win the game each location also has
their own game altering effects in a snap doubles
the amount of cosmic Cubes at stake you can Bluff
like you would in poker during a game by pulling a
snap in the middle of a game to double the amount
of cosmic Cubes at stake it's not a pay to win
situation you have to play to earn new cards
in all the card upgrades that you can earn are
just cosmetic only I'll put a link on screen and
in the description below that you can click on
be sure to check it out it's on both Steam and
mobile platforms right now and your account will
carry over between platforms so you can play on
your phone and on your desktop or a steam deck
or something like that with the same account so
be sure to check it out but the big news this week
was that Marvel Finally Revealed what's actually
happening with white Vision in the MCU after the
wandavision ending there are so many theories
like he's an Iron Man based character because he
comes from Jarvis Iron Man's AI so a lot of people
wondered if he'd show up during armor Awards
that's still possible because they just turned
that into a movie like armor Wars used to be a
TV series now it's going to be a movie because
they have such bigger Ambitions for it but he
kind of just flew off at the end of wandavision
never to be heard from again until the next big
Marvel project and Marvel just kind of waited to
announce what's actually going to happen so if you
remember in the finale it was revealed that Tyler
Hayward had been gaslighting Scarlet witch that
whole time in an attempt to get her to reactivate
vision's dead body with her chaos magic because
they couldn't do it using traditional means sword
had taken vision's body after Avengers Infinity
war and Avengers end game and tried to reactivate
him using traditional mechanical means because he
was worth billions and billions of dollars because
of all the vibranium and technology in his body
the big X Factor though to make another Marvel
reference was the Mind Stone in his forehead just
because it was so important in creating his more
humanoid personality like Vision was meant
to be the baby of Jarvis and Ultron combined
with a ton of vibranium and the mind Stone it was
very critical peace in Avengers Infinity war that
they talked about like how can we remove this
without completely destroying him it was a big
Suri storyline people still wondering about that
what did shuri do to vision was it going to work
if Thanos hadn't just ripped it right out of his
forehead in the storyline they adapted for white
Vision on Wanda Vision was basically taken right
out of the comics in fact right now they're just
calling the wandavision sequel series for white
Vision right now Vision Quest because that's
literally the name of the comic book story that
white Vision comes from and it's basically what
you saw happen during the course of wandavision
they explained with his backstory vision gets
destroyed then put back together Humpty Dumpty
style but when they bring him back they didn't
have Wonder man's brain patterns like they did
the first time to give him his personality so
he came back as this very cold unfeeling robot
this is where we have to some Wonder Man Easter
eggs because obviously they changed a little bit
for the MCU backstory they used the Mind Stone to
give him the personality instead of Wonder man's
brain patterns like they did in the comics Wonder
Man is a Marvel character developing a series 4
right now they just had a big announcement I'll
explain in a second but his real name in the MCU
is Simon Williams his day job is basically being
an actor in Hollywood like he's an LA based Marvel
character kind of like She-Hulk when they created
Vision they used his brain patterns to basically
give him his humanoid personality so that he's the
vision that you think of when you think of vision
from the comics when they put him back together
during The Vision Quest storyline he comes back
as this cold unfeeling robot kind of like white
Vision does on the series like minus the Mind
Stone he has no personality he's basically more
like a robot than he was before so the MCU Vision
Quest series will mostly be about him dealing
with all of vision's original memories that hex
Vision unlocked during their final fight which
really wasn't that much of a fight it was more of
like a Shakespearean argument like a gentlemanly
disagreement that they had between the two of them
like two nuclear bombs arguing with each other
which is a very Vision thing to do you remember
all the ship of Theseus memes after heck's Vision
had finished unlocking all those memories inside
white Vision because white Vision basically is
the original Vision just minus the Mind Stone
he flew off into the distance to just process
everything and the whole idea is that he's going
to be slowly remembering who he is and what his
life was before as part of that Elizabeth Olsen's
Scarlet Witch is supposed to come back they didn't
say how she's going to come back I think it'll
be a combination of different ways like all the
different ways you could bring an actor back
like they have flashback scenes of her as he's
remembering things with her then you have her
actually coming back like the Scarlet Witch that
we saw at the end of Doctor Strange 2 Multiverse
of Madness she didn't die if that wasn't clear
Willies knew she'd come back the whole idea with
Scarlet Witch is that she basically pulled down
the dark hole Temple that cathode had built
the big flare-up of chaos magic there when the
rock crumbled in on itself was basically a small
protective bubble forming around her like it was
her own unconscious sense of self-preservation
that just automatically protected her from all
that damage so at least until they bring her back
she's kind of like in this hibernation State sort
of like this weird limbo State she was always
going to come back for either Avengers 5 King
Dynasty but definitely Avenger six Secret Wars it
might not be till Secret Wars but she could always
come back for Avengers 5 as well I know a lot of
people also asking if Billy and Tommy are going to
come back too because they were little kids when
the series ended and a couple years go by they're
going to be way bigger my assumption is they'd
invoke them in some way but I'm not expecting a
ton of scenes with them they'll also be using them
in whatever Young Avengers series or movies that
they wind up doing with that team of characters
that they're slowly putting together but I think
they're waiting on Young Avengers till maybe after
Secret Wars just to give the kids more time to age
up so that they can actually play Teenagers most
of the other Young Avengers characters we've seen
so far that they're slowly introducing are much
much older and it's much easier for them to roll
into Young Avengers so I think they're just kind
of waiting a little bit for some of the actors to
age up the funny connection to Wonder Man in the
MCU though because obviously they've changed some
of the backstory of Wonder Man is that Marvel just
announced that Yaya Abdul Mateen the person who
who plays Black Manta in the Aquaman movies the
person who played Dr Manhattan also DC Comics so
also another comic book character is going to be
their Wonder Man which is actually a big surprise
going from DC to Marvel I guess that doesn't
imply good things for Black Manta inside the
DC Universe everyone press F to pay respects for
Black Manta what they're doing with the Wonder
Man character in the MCU though is they're going
with more of his actor storylines so the whole
idea is that Simon Williams day job is an actor
and they have a lot of these fake in Universe
Marvel parody movies like the ones that you saw
in Spider-Man far from home James Gunn also had
a version of this like he did a version of Simon
Williams Wonder Man in Guardians of the Galaxy 2
but it kind of wound up being a deleted scene like
Nathan Fillion played a version of Wonder Man for
him as Simon Williams with all these fake Marvel
movies like he played a version of Tony Stark he
was in a bunch of other movies and Marvel has Loki
season 2 coming up I've already done like a full
Loki season 2 trailer video so I'll link that
at the end of this and down in the description
below but part of the episodes take place in the
1970s and during that particular episode they have
a bunch of fake in univ verse movies mixed with
real movies from the 1970s including kingo's first
movie they even did a little bit of that during
Moon night with moon Knight's backstory like there
was this fake in Universe movie that helped
Inspire one of his personalities so Marvel's
just rolling with that idea and just developing
their version of Hollywood inside the MCU where
a lot of these movies get made the showrunner of
Wonder Man is also Daniel Cretton the person who
did the shangshi movie he's also the person who's
directing Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty so you have the
person who's doing Avengers 5 also doing Wonder
Man it sounds like Wonder Man is going to be a
pretty big character I'm not expecting a ton of
crossover between MCU Wonder Man in the white
Vision series though they're much more connected
in the comic so it's more of an Easter egg kind
of thing eventually the idea though is that white
Vision will become more like the original Vision
Without just completely resetting everything
to what it used to be like he is kind of a
different character now even though he has all of
his original Memories Back the whole idea is that
as he's processing all of his memories all that
put together in his new parts based basically
that form his body will result in him being a
completely new person so his relationship with
Scarlet Witch when she comes back will also be
a little bit different like this is her vision
but kind of not her vision at the same time so
I don't know if they're going to continue to
have a romantic relationship when she also comes
back too that's one of the reasons why you didn't
see vision during Doctor Strange 2 Multiverse of
Madness the way that Elizabeth Olsen explained it
though like this was her own sort of in-universe
explainer this wasn't something that Sam Raimi
told to her this was just something she came up
with on the spot when our Scarlet Witch went to
the other Universe to steal her children from
the other version of Scarlet Witch the reason
why there was no vision in their West View
house is because for some reason that version
of vision and that version of Scarlet Witch
had broken up like the a38 universe version
of vision was not talking to this version of
Scarlet Witch anymore they weren't together as
a couple there were also a lot of memes about
that at the end of wandavision as well naw,
me and Wanda we don't talk no more the other big
question a lot of people had going into Doctor
Strange too was why Scarlet Witch wasn't looking
for Vision as well like we knew white Vision was
out there had all of vision's original memories
why didn't she care about him the real answer
is because Marvel was developing the spin-off
Series where he processes his memories and they
wanted to focus the story more on her finding her
children the in-universe story-based reason for
her not looking for white Vision I think is her
emotionally moving on from Vision himself like
her vision died so she knew that white Vision was
not her vision which is why she wasn't rushing to
go grab and bring him back so it implies in the
future when they're all back together on screen
at the same time they'll just be cordial to each
other like they'll be friends but it's not like
they're going to move in together or anything
like that there's been a bunch of other news
about other big Marvel series they're working on
right now obviously in the next year or so as more
of these series come out we'll start to hear more
and more about other stuff they're developing and
also the other new big change that Marvel has
made is that not everything that isn't getting
a movie is automatically becoming a Disney
plus series now because the werewolf By Night
Halloween special was so successful the special
presentation one off is a much bigger thing with
thin marble so for instance Silver Surfer they're
saying now might be a special presentation like
a one-off that they released right before the
events of the new Fantastic Four movie so it's
just another opportunity for them to do really
cool one-off projects for characters that don't
really have a story that's worth six to eight
episodes aren't necessarily commercial or like
big enough to Warrant a giant 200 million dollar
movie but because black panther wakanda forever
is coming out really soon there'll be a bunch of
news about what's happening with the future of the
Black Panther characters of course I'll do videos
about that too along with my post credit scene
video full Easter eggs breakdown for the movie
so I'll name a new giveaway winner the next time
I post a Marvel video everyone click here for
my house of the Dragon alternate ending deleted
scenes video alternate story lines and click here
for that Loki season 2 trailer breakdown in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!